outside the court activist the reverend
al sharpton
led the floyd family in prayer we are
now
in the shadows of a courthouse praying
for justice
inside crucial evidence from a police
use of force instructor
a man who's taught hundreds of police
officers including derrick chauvin
at issue the way george floyd was pinned
to the ground in may last year
not a recognized police technique said
lieutenant johnny mercel
something that could cause trouble
breathing a knee on the neck would be
something that
does happen in use of force that isn't
unauthorized
and under what circumstances would that
be authorized how long can you do that
i don't know if there's a time frame it
would depend on the circumstance of the
time
which would include what the type of
resistance you're getting from the
subject that you're putting me on
and so if there was uh say for example
uh the subject was under control
and handcuffed would this be authorized
i would say no the defense argued in
cross-examination
that officers had to consider the
possibility that even when it appeared
george floyd was unconscious
there was still a threat earlier the
court heard from cair yang
a crisis training coordinator and he
acknowledged
that some police techniques were
necessary but the policy
was clear the policy requires that when
it's safe and feasible
that we shall de-escalate and he
insisted force should only be used when
necessary
the defense is trying to suggest that
derek shoving did what was necessary to
protect himself
and his colleagues and the growing crowd
complicated decisions on the ground
the prosecution accepts the use of force
as a necessary part of the job
but they are trying to prove that derek
chauvin went too far
and that caused the death of george
floyd alan fisher al jazeera
at the chauvin murder trial in
minneapolis